hello if you're watching this video I
didn't make it uh no I'm kidding I did
make it I just watched a lot of
television or Netflix and I recorded a
lot of stuff and I wrote a lot of stuff
and it I did it for you but uh no I'm
happy I liked it I liked the show I just
thought it'd be good to give you just my
overall thoughts on the season uh just
as a whole sorry if if this isn't like
easy to follow and just understand I
didn't write my thoughts down or
anything so just kind of fresh I'm just
gonna kind of wing it my name is philipp
molina by the way Ted got me a spray so
I can talk more Thank You Ted all right
so my grand grand is thought like the
thing that I can kept thinking like the
whole time was um just the fact that
like since this main thing is the show's
good and one of the reasons I think it's
good is cuz it's good at being a show
whether or not these are superheroes um
like Jessica sure as has super strength
but she'll kind of barely uses it she
barely flies or barely leap I and then
you'll sure you're like killgrave uses
his powers a lot but kind of right
because the show is ultimately more
about like manipulation right being in
control being in control of yourself
being in control of others or at least
wanting to be in control of others and I
feel like if this were written about a
master manipulator like you know
Hannibal Lecter or something someone who
wanted just like brilliant guys I the
show still works he can still talk
people into killing themselves or doing
things that are for his own benefit so I
think that's kind of like one of the
most just impressive takeaways from the
series is just like wow you know that's
that's kind of how you do a show without
making it about the fact that people
have superpowers they also happen to
just be people that are interesting
right like and that are going through
some and like that alone is an
interesting thing to see so kudos on
that I the next thing I I think
is worth mentioning is I ain't like how
can animals shirts at at first is David
Tennant like amazing like such a great
performance by far he may kill great my
favorite Marvel Cinematic Universe
knowing like absolutely the guy was a
monster he was
sadistic and just like evil but the
duality that David Tennant was able to
play where that was one moment another
moment boom he's just your creepy
ex-boyfriend and it's it's sad and he's
just pathetic right and the fact that he
could swing between those two like
effortlessly and honestly genuinely be
kind of funny sometimes that is like
just like Bravo when that's amazing
acting oh I I wouldn't even I wouldn't
nearly have liked this series as much if
if it weren't just how much he brought
to it that that character it's it's kind
of scrappy that uh that he seems to be
dead uh cuz that is like you know that
guy's up there pretty much with like the
Joker from Dark Knight or something like
there's very few villains that achieve
this level of like monster and genuine
terror like you're you're terrified of
what this guy's capable of I got an
email sorry you're terrible you're
terrified of what this guy is capable of
but you also like you're also scared for
as like a viewer because the backstory
they gave them he's not evil because
he's got a vendetta he claims you know
he's even wants vengeance against
Jessica whatever but the dudes evil
because he grew up getting everything he
ever wanted and that means that's in the
human condition somewhere like humanity
is capable of that not just they didn't
say the powers you know they it mixed up
his brain and scrambled it it was like
Oh what happens if you take a
ten-year-old a little dick of a kid and
give him everything you want it's like a
Twilight Zone episode he goes nuts with
power and he becomes terrible and we all
could have been that if we weren't
raised right it just gave me calls it
out oh you're gonna blame bad parenting
but it's just interesting that like it
seemed like that definitely was a big
part of it was bad parenting and just
humanity hick is capable of awful nurse
and that's sad uh but that's part of why
I like being able to play a villain that
makes you feel all these complex things
that is is an amazing amazing
performance that's why he's my favorite
villain so far that we've seen uh I am
tired of rambling so much so I'm just
gonna say things and we can chop them up
so here we go I think this show is
really an important one and it's gonna I
mean it's really obvious that it's
important in terms of the front from a
feminist perspective that women needed a
show like this in the Marvel Universe
and so did men everyone needs a show
like this because yeah obviously like
girl power and she's strong and you know
she don't need no help from no man uh
and that's all great but we also the
whole series is is about what women kind
of go through all the time and as a man
watching it you kind of do connect Oh
girls daily have to make sure that they
get to be in control of their own lives
like they're constantly making an
argument like no thank you I know what I
want to do with my life I and society
does kind of push him to do it I do
remember there was that scene with the
guy um the mechanic or something and
she's like how do I get to the hospital
and he was like and she wasn't nice and
he was like rude girls are lonely girls
she's like yeah that's the point met a
lot of men can drive women to be that
way but they need to cuz they like if
she's if she's not rude to him then he
gets the wrong idea and then it's a you
know catch-22 you're you're damned if do
you do you're damned if you don't
all right so the series like Marvel
movies and shows and all these things
they frequently they obviously like
appeal to a male demographic maybe a
little bit more than women so this is
like subversive right it's like a little
it's a little mind control thing that
the series creator I was able to sneak
in there of just like I know a lot of
dudes are watching this so let's inform
them a lot about what it's like to be a
woman in New York but kind of a woman
anywhere I and that's why I think
there's that importance of the smile
thing it's it's there from the first
episode to the last episode right and
it's just a thing
that I know for a fact that a lot of
girls have complained to me about this
idea of smiling that they have to smile
and they when they're not smiling
strange men just approach them to just
say hey you should smile and it's like
why I don't smile randomly I'm smiling
now in prison but you don't always have
to smile and if a smile is false then
what's the point of smiling if you have
to be told to smile do they count so the
fact that no it doesn't count means that
the person requesting to smile it's for
them you're you're smiling for their
reasons and and thus and that's what
women go through all the time they walk
down the street they're not smiling
because they're walking on the street
they're not you know saintly like high
on ecstasy or something so they they're
not smiling and if someone's like hey
you need to smile that's for that person
they're trying to control you for their
own benefit it's manipulation it so runs
through the entire series but I think
that that's definitely where that's
coming from
guys don't tell women to smile it's it's
not our business to tell them to smile
don't smile when they're happy why don't
you do something make them happy and
then they'll smile just a food for
thought but that said so
so really smart idea putting that in
this show that you know is gonna be
watched by a lot of guys uh I think
there's still room obviously for a lot
form women in in Marvel and in DC and
everywhere and anything but I really
like seeing the feminine perspective on
things it was really opening when we saw
a woman walked into New York for ten
hours or whatever it was I I open it
d'orsay i opening or just opening hope I
said it's really eye-opening to see that
I just have a gaping hole after watching
that what am I saying
anyway I so hopefully more things like
this will do that for society until
we're all just the freakin same so much
for not rambling okay sorry there was
the there wasn't daredevil and if I mean
there were some references I know a lot
of people are like that's probably him
in the opening credits the boxer with a
little bit of
Vandana whatever I may be Devils him
maybe wasn't but you know I didn't meant
necessarily miss him but by the end of
the whole thing I did like that we saw
Claire temple I kind of I wanted to see
her earlier but then she wasn't there
but then she was there at the end and
she was she's so charming
she was just charming I like seeing that
little relationship it also reminds me I
found the relationship between Jessica
and Trish very charming too I really
liked those two girls just hanging out
and being funny with each other so it's
great
what's nice oh great so one right going
right to it
uh-huh they made it rape in this it is
not rape in the comics it's it's some
people today it's worse than rape some
people wouldn't but but it almost was
like that word wasn't even said in the
comics like the comic dropped the f-bomb
all the time but they couldn't say rapes
interesting I and so it's good that the
show didn't like shy away from that like
we're talking about a guy who was a
freakin he wanting you wants he
takes course he ends up raping women and
it's it's a very visceral literal way to
interpret what the what Jessica and and
hope and mind-control victims are
suffering it's very similar to the the
feelings of a rape victim so to make it
part of that story kind of just makes a
lot of sense like you
we've never been mind-controlled I hope
you haven't been mind-controlled so we
don't know what that feels like
but we know the concept of rape and how
terrible that would feel and so it did
help anchor it I think emotionally to be
able to like you don't like rape right
that's what this feels like except it's
actually in some ways it was darker
because the purity of mind control you
think you want it and that starts to get
into that world of like you know where
you Vic victim remorse right were they
they think they're asking for it so it
just we have so many complex feelings
about rape that to mirror it in in the
mind control stuff actually is a very
smart move because we get to feel
complex feelings about a made up thing
so good choice
it's definitely the dark they did it
they did everything that I thought they
would do and more for sure it's
definitely the darkest thing Marvel has
done and good you don't have to make
everything dark I don't need the
Fantastic Four to be dark but some dark
stuff
and two just like in life right not
every day is spent at a funeral and not
every day is fed you know at sky Zone
which is the name of a trampoline place
that does not sponsor me but I'll take
the sponsorship sky Zone it's the
opposite of a funeral
Krysten Ritter was great I thought she
totally nailed the part she doesn't look
like Jessica Jones in the comics but
otherwise she is broken just like I like
somebody's to check on Krysten Ritter
because she looked a little like oh I'm
cute but like I look damaged and if of
course she just plays it really well I
kind of like that like she also
surprised me with how like badass she
can be she isn't a damsel she like she
was on Breaking Bad right but she's not
the one who knocked she is the one who
breaks the locks look she doesn't even
care she just busts in and doesn't it
like I don't know I totally bought her I
thought she did a great job
totally admirable work uh David Tennant
still like stole the entire show but no
one can name it compared to what he did
all right I'm trying to think if there's
anything I didn't like um the twin
subplot was weird I don't know that I
didn't like it uh it was just weird
um the hogarth subplot what okay so
there definitely were parallels I could
see reasons why we're seeing two
versions of a broken relationship we
don't know what again what it's like to
be mind-controlled but we do know a lot
of us know what it's like to be in a bad
relationship and have a bad breakup so
we they were able to kind of weave us
and connect us through it but you could
technically probably cut them tire story
out and it stills mostly same show
except you would lose the thousand cuts
thing which was amazing and terrifying
but amazing so I love that story line
but uh that's okay no we don't have to
love everything the pacing I thought was
mostly good near the end it doesn't help
that I've not slept at all to be in an
episode where they keep talking about
needing to go to sleep so that episode
kind of like was a little bit sleepy for
me but uh
oh and then so the nuke subplot or the
the officer Simpson sup law I am
actually excited about it because it's
like oh so many cool things can happen
if they keep going with that and they're
going to introduce all these ten
potentially more super-powered
characters next season maybe but I
there's a lot of cool stuff there and I
love the way that he's equated to like
an evil Captain America like that's so
true to his story in the comics but also
so perfect for this like reflection is
negative reflection on the Avengers
universe and Jessica Jones so it's
really cool just watching it the whole
time with the idea that like that dudes
you know bizarro Captain America even
looked like him but they kind of like
did his stuff like way too quickly like
just jammed in there cuz I I know that
there was people watching it like
binging with me and you just like cool
oh interesting this character is getting
a little dark he's taking flag colored
pills and he's talking to a shadowy
government organization and it just kind
of like whoa
takes off really fast there with his
stuff so I'm so excited about what it
means but it also was like wow there's a
lot of a lot happens really fast with
them I'm also realizing that my voice is
all over the place so if you're
listening to bad sound right now it's
cuz we had to use a backup microphone
because I'm unreliable at the moment
you're welcome okay overall of course I
do it again I thought it was great I
probably am gonna end up watching it
again I'm sure there's plenty that you
want me to talk about that I'm just
totally blanking on it because I'm sorry
the whole thing's a blur right now I
remember they loved glass it's a big
glass of specific part of this in
doorways but if there's anything that
you think I miss now or you want to know
my opinion on I probably did go into it
in my in-depth analysis that I did after
every single episode which Evernote was
the best idea to get a do every single
time so I look forward to - I'm gonna do
those episodes are gonna be coming out
over the next couple of days and I ever
easter-egg I saw every piece of analysis
I could do I jammed in there and you'll
see how I became this helps you if you
keep up with them I but I'm sure I'll
put an annotation here somewhere for how
to start that or go to those 13 episodes
thirteen sorry I'm not fainted in my
phone and pay attention to you I'm sorry
watch those when they're up some of them
are probably up by the time you're
watching this and in the comments here
let's talk about the whole series and
ask me any
you wanna you can tweet at me at fimo
and here
spoilers galore if you want them because
we all have finished it and the ones
that I'm going to post about all the
other episodes trying to keep spoilers
out of those unless it's like up to that
episode so like episode 1 only episode 1
episode 2 can do 1 & 2 whatever because
the people that are watching those are
people that weren't as lucky as lucky
has us got to bend it all at once
I imagine some people will be watching
this you know over Thanksgiving and all
times when you're avoiding your family
so just try to keep spoilers out of all
those if you if you can please thank you
so much for sticking with me through
what's gonna be really interesting
journey I love you guys I'm Phillip
milena by the way bye I need all the
sleep I dropped the mic not not in a
cool way